so just a quick reminder inshallah so
I'm going to tell you guys where I am as
you can see it's full of under
construction
have you guys ever been in a restaurant
and it's time to pray Salah don't turn
off listen carefully
and you're like oh man my family you're
enjoying yourself the food is amazing
you're drinking orange juice and all
this kind of stuff
and you have to praise Allah time
and some people hate it dislike it for
some people you have to do it I wanted
your catches to imagine because whenever
I'm in restaurants I like to reflect and
I look around and I'm like everyone's
enjoying delicious food wow and the
European people look at each other we
tried that you can win have you tried
this have you tried that and everyone's
eating
but for a moment just think to yourself
subhanallah look how we're enjoying the
blessings Allah has given us we're
eating it but when it's time for Salah
oh man nah forget that just think for a
second bonuses well lie if this is not
in gratitude and Allah says in the Quran
indeed mankind is ungrateful to his Lord
and He himself is a witness nobody else
you yourself as a witness to that
brothers and sisters I had to pray and
I'm not doing this to sound holy the
fact that you guys might think I'm
trying to show off will be holy shows
the level we're at as muslims
subhanallah praying Salah is the basis
of the basis that we should be doing I
had to find the spot and I had to come
to this room that's under construction
yeah obviously I made sure it's safe
about him and I had to pray and today I
wasn't wearing my socks to even wipe
over the socks the point is the
following Brown sisters be grateful to
Allah we worship Allah not because of
what he does for us but because of who
he is and he's deserving of it do not
miss your Salah for anything and Ponder
the food that you're eating the blessing
that you have when you sat at that table
you enjoyed it go thank your lord
just a little reminder till next time
may Allah
and don't even miss once nothing once
may God bless you guys until next time